[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: So I'm
going to come to 8.20--
Special Relativity.
It's a great pleasure to
introduce David Kaiser.
David is a faculty in
the physics department.
He's also a
historian of science.
So he's in a super
great position
to talk about Einstein
and special relativity
and give kind of the
frame for this class.
So please welcome David.
And take it along.
DAVID KAISER: Great.
Well, hello, everyone.
Happy New Year.
Welcome back at least
virtually to MIT.
It's really a great pleasure
to talk with you today
about this material.
I love this material.
So hopefully you can all
see that first slide--
smiling Einstein on the bicycle.
OK.
So I want to talk about
three main parts today
for the material.
And we'll talk about
how all of the most
accomplished physicists were
thinking about motion of bodies
through space and time
during the middle, late years
of the 19th century, roughly,
say, 100 to 150 years ago,
give or take, because
that really sets up
a pretty sharp contrast
with how at the time
a rather young and
very little known
person named Albert Einstein
began asking similar questions
but often in very
different ways.
So we'll start with some
of this context of what
was happening before Einstein
even came on the scene
to help us better make sense
of why his approach seemed
really so unfamiliar and
so surprising at the time.
And then for the last part--
I find it really
fascinating, drawing on work
from some of my friends and
colleagues, other historians--
we'll try to ask, what was
going on with Einstein?
Why was Einstein's
approach so different?
And can we make sense of
it since it wasn't just
the ordinary routine that we
might have otherwise expected?
That's that last part
about coordinating clocks.
Well, let's jump right in.
Let's start not
with Albert Einstein
but with another very familiar
name, James Clerk Maxwell.
I thought about growing a
beard like that during COVID.
I haven't made much progress.
But that's a typical 19th
century, fine Cambridge beard--
Cambridge, England.
So we all know Maxwell's name.
Many of you probably
own a t-shirt
with Maxwell's equations on it.
If you do, I'm very jealous.
I don't have one anymore.
Anyway, so we still
use his approach
to electromagnetism, as of
course you all know very well.
And we've been able
to boil it down
to basically a tweet
or a single t-shirt.
It turns out, as
you may know, what
we now call Maxwell's equations
were hammered out by Maxwell
and actually some
other colleagues
during the 1860s
and early 1870s,
so approximately 150 years ago.
And in fact when he
first wrote them down,
they weren't in such
a nice, compact form.
It was in a 900-page, two-volume
treatise that was first
published in 1873--
two volumes, a
total of 900 pages.
It was a weapon.
You could hurt someone
with these books,
it was so fat, even though
now we can boil it down
to a simple t-shirt.
And so what's even
more interesting to me
is that even though we still
use Maxwell's equations, what
we think they say
about the world
is really, really
different than what
Maxwell and his
immediate circle thought.
And the biggest
difference of all
is that for Maxwell and really
for all of his contemporaries
and his students, the equations
of electricity and magnetism,
as far as they were
concerned, had everything
to do with some
physical substance,
a medium that they called
the ether that they assumed
must be spread evenly
throughout the entire universe,
filling every nook
and cranny of space.
So all of the phenomena
that we would associate
with electricity or magnetism,
the flow of currents,
the splaying of iron
filings around a bar magnet,
and even much more
complicated things,
to Maxwell and his group,
these were all just
evidence of the state of
stress of this underlying
physical medium.
It was like a springy,
substantial, resistive medium
that they called the ether.
And he says that in the
opening pages, for example,
of his now very famous
treatise and throughout,
that the whole point of studying
this field, as far as he
was concerned, was to study the
behavior of the distribution
of stress in this medium
extending continuously
throughout the
universe, the ether.
It wasn't just Maxwell.
His a little bit more senior
colleague, William Thomson,
who went on to be known as
Lord Kelvin, like the Kelvin
temperature scale
and many things
we still use from
Thomson's work,
he wanted to give a
sense to non-scientists
a few years later in
a popular lecture what
all the excitement was about.
He said, here's
what we're doing.
We want you to get a sense
for what we're doing.
We're studying the physics of
this elastic, physical medium
called the ether.
And he instructed his very
elite, very fancy audience
who went to one of
these popular lectures,
stick your hand in a bowl
of jelly, he tells them.
And see how it
wiggles and vibrates
as you move your hand around.
That's the highest of high-end
physics in the 1860s and '70s.
It was all about
understanding the behavior
of this elastic medium
called the ether.
And that had very specific
follow-on implications
for this group.
So one of the first things
that you all know already,
one of the most exciting
features of Maxwell's work
that really got himself excited
and solidified his reputation
was this unexpected unification
that he put together
in the 1860s.
Not only was there
a deep relationship
between electricity
and magnetism.
That had been wondered about
but never really formalized.
But even more surprising,
that these two areas,
electricity and
magnetism, were also
deeply associated with optics,
with the propagation of light.
So it was Maxwell, as I'm
sure you know and probably
have already done
this on problem sets
by now yourselves--
using Maxwell's
equations, you can
derive the quantitative
behavior of light
as it travels through space.
Light, as Maxwell
intuited, was nothing
but a certain pattern
of propagating
electric and magnetic fields.
Again, to Maxwell, these were
propagating in this material,
physical ether.
They were disturbances
propagating,
skittering through this physical
stuff that filled all of space.
And in fact, by trying
to calculate the speed
with which disturbances would
travel through space based
on other properties
of the ether that he
and his colleagues
had already measured,
basically sets up
like spring constants,
he found that the
speed of propagation
would be equal to the
value that had already
been calculated many years
before for the speed with which
light travels.
And he says in his own words,
in this lovely old-fashioned
phrasing, "The velocity of
transverse undulations"--
a certain kind of wave--
"in our hypothetical
medium agrees so exactly
with the velocity
of light calculated
from optical experiments"--
mostly astronomy at the time--
"that we can scarcely
avoid the inference
that light consists of
the transverse undulations
of the same medium
which is the cause
of electric and
magnetic phenomena."
That's why his book
was 900 pages, right?
Today we can put
in on a t-shirt.
He was really just walking
through this very old fashioned
language to come
to the point saying
light was nothing but a certain
kind of pattern in the ether.
And so in fact they often
called this not just the ether
but an even fancier name.
They called it the
luminiferous ether.
And from the Latin, it
means "light bearing"
or "light carrying."
So "lumin", like "lumos" for
you Harry Potter fans, that part
you probably recognize.
And the "ferous" is
like a Ferris wheel.
That means, like, to carry
or to move through space.
So this was the light-bearing
or light-carrying ether.
And that's what
Maxwell and really all
of his contemporaries
were convinced
was most exciting
about Maxwell's work,
that this was a way
of characterizing
the state of the ether including
these optical phenomena.
OK, so that's where things
stood in the 1860s and 1870s.
But that led to a whole
new set of questions.
And the next generation
quite understandably
wanted to kind of
follow up on that
and ask ways to
generalize that framework.
Maxwell's work
had really assumed
that there was no relative
motion between either
the source of light or
the receiver of light,
that everything was analyzed
in what we would now
call the same rest frame,
or frame of reference,
as the ether itself.
But of course that wasn't
the most general situation,
as Maxwell's own contemporaries
or the next younger generation
began to wonder about.
One of the most influential
of that next wave
is this gentleman shown
here, Hendrik Lorentz
from the Netherlands,
from Leiden.
So Lorentz wanted to ask about
the electrodynamics of moving
bodies.
What if either the emitter of
light or the receiver or both
were moving with respect to
this all-pervasive medium?
And so Lorentz,
as we'll see, had
really two distinct
motivations in mind
when he tried to think about
the electrodynamics of moving
bodies, or let's say optics for
moving sources or receivers.
He had a kind of mathematical
set of quandaries.
And we'll talk
about those first.
But he also had a series of very
puzzling experimental results.
So he had an
empirical set of ideas
that we'll come to in a
moment and also these more
formal or mathematical.
We'll start with the math.
Lorentz was really one of
the best-trained, leading
mathematical
physicists of his age.
So he knew very well how
to handle relative motion.
Galileo had derived
that in the 1610s.
That was hardly
news in the 1890s.
We would do what we still
call the Galileo-Newton
transformation.
For example, Galileo
wrote very famously
in his charming dialogues
in the 17th century,
if you watch your friend float
down a river on a boat that
moves at a constant speed,
neither speeding up nor slowing
down, then you
know very well how
to compare the coordinates
between you, sitting
at rest on the
bank of that river,
and your friend as she
floats down on her boat,
that what you call the
origin, the spatial origin,
of your coordinate system, you
can fix at, say, x equals 0.
But your friend could call
the center of her boat
the origin for her
coordinate system.
And then you can see how
her system coordinates will
move with respect to yours.
If the boat moves
at a constant speed,
little v, then you
just have to calculate
the offset between where the
origin, the center of her boat,
is as it floats further
and further down the river.
So what she calls the origin
of her spatial coordinates
will be offset from yours
because this relative motion,
this relative drift.
Meanwhile, as Newton
himself famously said
in the beginning
of his Principia
where we learn about
Newton's laws of mechanics,
that time is time is time.
There's some absolute time.
He actually referred it
to the sensorium of God.
He thought there was only one
possible time to consider.
And so formally
there'd be no change
to the rate at which
your clock ticked
versus the rate at which
your friend's clock ticked
on her boat.
This is called the
Galileo-Newton transformation.
I made a big deal out of it.
You probably would have
done this in your sleep.
Lorentz did this in his sleep.
However, it drove
him to nightmares
because when he
then applied this
to Maxwell's really
beautiful and much newer
set of equations for
things like optics
or the propagation of electric
and magnetic disturbances
in the ether, he
found that in that
transformed reference
frame if you
take into account that relative
motion between either emitter
or receiver of light, then
Maxwell's beautiful description
of light, his quantitative
description, looked very ugly.
And in particular,
it would no longer
suggest that light should
behave as oscillating
sines and cosines.
It worked beautifully
with Maxwell's equations
if you look only at both sources
and receivers of light that
are fixed in place and
not moving with respect
to the ether.
Once you apply the very, very
well-known transformation
to take into account
relative motion,
then your description of
light gets all literally out
of whack.
And this was a mathematical
conundrum for Lorentz.
It didn't seem to make any
sense because on the Earth,
on the moving Earth presumably
moving through the ether,
he and his colleagues
could measure
light to behave like beautiful
sines and cosines all the time.
So we have an empirical reminder
that Maxwell's description
seems really, really accurate
for describing optics
even on our own moving
ship of the Earth.
So this is a real
conundrum for him.
He was a very, very
clever, mathematically
gifted physicist.
So he introduced a
mathematical clue.
He introduced a mathematical
stopgap to address this.
He called it local time.
And he was actually very
clear in his writings.
He said it was a
mathematical fiction--
his word.
It was literally just
a mathematical trick.
If he introduced a
new transformation
for the time variable, so when
you compare your coordinates
with those of your
friend on the boat,
what if you actually did make
a transformation of t prime,
not just of x prime?
And the transformation
he kind of worked out,
he reverse engineered
the form it
would need to have so
that Maxwell's description
of light waves would be
restored to the very simple form
that Maxwell himself had written
down a few years earlier.
So this is where we still
call this the Lorentz
transformation.
Many of you might have seen it.
If not, you'll have plenty
of time to learn about it
and practice it during IAP.
We call it Lorentz,
not Einstein,
because Lorentz derived these
equations first in a series
of papers in the 1890s.
And he was responding to this
question of the electrodynamics
of moving bodies.
How do you preserve this
beautiful description of light
from Maxwell even if there's
relative motion with respect
to the ether?
He said it was a trick.
It was merely mathematics.
But it would at least
get the right form back.
So that was the
mathematical motivation.
Lorentz, as we know,
was also concerned
about an empirical or
experimental curiosity.
He was following
very closely the work
of a US-based physicist
named Albert Michelson.
Michelson's story is
really fascinating.
I won't take too much time
now, but super interesting.
He was actually an immigrant
from what's now Germany,
was often part of
Poland, central Europe.
He moved to the US when he
was about two years old, very
young, and was raised
right around the time
of the gold rush in California.
And before I get
carried away, I'll
stop talking about
Michelson, although he's
super interesting.
So what Michelson
wound up doing was
he was fascinated by this
question of Maxwell waves,
of waves of electricity
and magnetism in the ether.
And he was convinced that
if we are on this moving
ship of the Earth moving
through the ether,
that should have a measurable
impact on the light waves
that we can produce and
measure here on Earth.
So he set really his life's
goal starting from very,
very early trying
to build devices,
extremely sensitive
instruments with which
he could measure the
fact that the Earth was
moving through this ether.
Like all his
contemporaries, Michelson
believed without any
hesitation that there must
exist the material, the ether.
What else could light waves be
but disturbances in the ether?
And then he figured
that much like
if a bicyclist going
for a bike ride,
we should be able
to tell that we're
moving through that medium.
So before I describe his device
called the interferometer,
let me just give a little more
of an analogy for why Michelson
was so convinced there should
be a measurable effect.
If we walk outside our houses,
which is now a luxury--
we can still do
it with masks on--
walk outside on a still day when
there's no wind or no breeze,
we won't feel any
particular wind on our face
if we're standing still.
So we're outside in
a physical medium.
There's a physical atmosphere.
But if we're at rest with
respect to that atmosphere,
if there's no wind, we
don't feel it on our face.
On the other hand, if
it's still a still day,
there's no breeze, when
we get on our bicycle
and pedal really quickly, we'll
now feel a breeze on our face
because we're moving through
that physical medium.
We're moving through
the Earth's atmosphere.
Even if the atmosphere
seems to be perfectly
at rest, no strong
breeze, no hurricane,
whatever, if we're going
quickly enough through it,
we'll feel a breeze on our face.
And Michelson thought
the same thing
should be happening
for light waves
as they are carried by the
Earth through this medium, not
the Earth's atmosphere but this
all-pervasive, light-bearing
ether.
So he really thought it
would be like the bicyclist.
Now, his real genius was
devising this device,
we now call it the
interferometer,
with which he could
try to measure
the impact of that motion of
the Earth, the entire Earth,
through the medium.
So he took a source of light.
Today we use lasers
because they're awesome
and they're also monochromatic.
Their light shines basically
at one frequency, or very
dominantly one frequency.
Lasers of course weren't
available to Michelson.
So he used very bright
sodium arc lamps.
Sodium lamps will shine
mostly at one dominant color,
not nearly so monochromatic
as modern lasers.
But they were the industry
standard at the time.
So he basically
took sodium lamps
that mostly shine a particular
yellow color, shined them
at what we now call
a beam splitter.
It was a half-silvered
mirror, as its name implies,
that would let half
the light through.
It would act like a window
roughly half the time.
But it would act like a mirror
the other half of the time.
So half of this incident beam
will go right through this
as if it were just
a plate of glass.
It would be transmitted.
It will then make its way to
a fully reflecting mirror--
sorry-- a fully reflecting
mirror at the end of the path.
It'll be reflected
and come back.
And then, again, half
of that return light
will be reflected by the mirror
and come out to a screen.
Meanwhile, you can run
the same kind of story
for light that gets
deflected towards path 2.
From that same, single
incident source,
half of the incident
beam will be
reflected by that beam splitter,
that half-silvered mirror.
It'll travel a path down to a
fully reflecting mirror, come
back.
And then half of that returning
light will be transmitted.
So you have light coming
together on some detector
screen, that it started
out as a single light wave
from a single, nearly
monochromatic source.
But you split it into
two beams so the beams
travel different paths.
And now the light starts out
fully in phase with itself.
It's one light beam.
So crests are with crests
and troughs with troughs.
And the idea was
that you then split
it to set up a race
to see if there
was any difference in
the travel for light
that traveled through
path 1 and out
to the screen versus
light that traveled
path 2 and back to the screen.
All the light starts as a single
light wave in sync or in phase
with itself.
If there was any
difference in the travels
of that light between
path 1 and path 2,
you should see a shift in
the interference pattern.
Crests should no longer
arrive lining up with crests
or troughs with troughs.
You should see a very
characteristic set
of interference fringes.
What is called an
interferometer,
extremely sensitive.
Now, his idea was if,
like the bicyclist,
we're on the moving Earth, then
the path is heading directly
into the ether.
That is, say, the path that's
along the Earth's motion
through the ether should be
just like the bicyclists feeling
the direct headwind of
that breeze directly
on her or his face.
That means the effective speed--
let's say this is the direction
of the Earth's motion.
The effective speed with
which this light beam
could travel toward
its mirror should
be experiencing a direct
headwind for its upward path
and a direct tailwind
for its downward path.
It should have a different
speed than the light that
follows the more orthogonal path
so that even the light starts
out perfectly in
phase, you should find
a shift in the
interference fringes
because the light's effective
speed through the medium
is different for
path 1 than path 2--
again, an analogy to the
ether wind of a bicyclist
through the atmosphere.
Not only that-- a
little foreshadowing
for what's to come later--
this device is so
sensitive, it's
sensitive to second order
in a very small quantity.
So it could measure
differences to the second order
in the relative speed of, say,
the Earth through the ether
compared to the speed of light.
So that's called a second
order because it goes
this small quantity squared.
That's how sensitive this
really ingenious device was.
And as many of
you might know, we
use interferometers all
the time now in all kinds
of industrial applications.
Even more, my
favorite example is
from our friends who detect
gravitational waves with LIGO.
That's essentially a
super-sized interferometer
with very, very similar
principles of design.
So Michelson was doing
this really cool work.
It was among the
earliest work that any
of the super fancy,
elite European scientists
paid any attention to
coming out of the US.
Michelson was
among the first who
made even the people like
Hendrik Lorentz sit up and pay
attention at a time when the US
was still otherwise pretty much
a scientific backwater.
So it's a really cool idea.
It's a remarkably clever
design for a device.
Michelson built a
small prototype.
Then he super sized it with
his colleague Edward Morley.
They built a device
11 meters long
for each arm, so roughly
33 or 34 feet long--
huge, huge for its
day, very long arms.
They floated the whole
thing in a vat of mercury,
which I don't recommend.
But they were trying to
tamp down any vibrations
from nearby cable cars.
They wanted to have a clean
laboratory environment.
Then they did this
for years and years
and years, months and
months and years and years
because, of course,
you never know
what the ether's
actual rest frame is.
Who's to say that
at this moment,
this is the direction
of the Earth's
motion through the ether?
Maybe it's this direction or
some other angle in between.
They would look for day
to night variations.
They would look for
annual variations
as the Earth went around
its orbit around the sun.
They would try to find any
time, day or night, winter
versus spring, year
after year when
they could measure some
measurable offset or change
in those interference fringes
because at some point,
this direction
should have lined up
with the Earth's
direction of motion,
even it wouldn't be every time.
That's why they kept doing this
over and over and over again.
And as you might know,
they found nothing.
So after years of
painstaking data collection,
they found no compelling
empirical evidence
of the Earth's motion
through the ether.
Michelson won the Nobel Prize
for this and related work.
He was an astoundingly
accomplished experimentalist.
He was the first
US-based physicist
to win the Nobel Prize.
He lived 20 more
years after that
and died considering
himself a failure.
So I hope you all
win the Nobel Prize.
And I hope you think
better of yourselves
and give yourselves more credit.
Michelson knew for certain
the ether must exist.
And yet he had
failed to find it.
So Lorentz was following
this back in Europe.
And this was really his
second main motivation
to think about these
funny ways of handling
coordinates in what we now call
the Lorentz transformation.
So I mentioned his
mathematical concerns
about the transformation
properties
of Maxwell's equations.
He was also following
the Michelson-Morley work
with great interest
and citing it.
And we know he was really
following each update.
So he was concerned
about this failure
to measure a shift in
the interference fringes.
But Lorentz said,
oh, but actually
maybe there's a physical
reason to account for that.
If there really is, as
he knew there must be,
this physical, resistive
medium, kind of elastic medium
through which the Earth and
everything else is moving,
then there must be a force
exerted by that viscous medium
on every single
atom and molecule
making up all the stuff
in Michelson's device
as well as in everything else.
And so it would be like
picturing a beach ball.
If you try to drag a
beach ball underwater,
in a resistive medium,
the shape will be deformed
along the direction of motion.
If you drag that beach ball
fast enough underwater,
it will shrink in the
direction of motion.
It will be deformed
like this picture here.
And so Lorentz said
that must be happening
for every bit of matter
in the arm of Michelson's
interferometer that's most
subject to that resistive force
of the ether.
There should be a contraction
along the direction of motion.
So then, again
because he's a very
gifted mathematical
physicist, he
calculated exactly how
much shift must there
be for the resultant path to be
shortened just enough to make
it a tie race after all.
So the arm of the
interferometer that's
experiencing this
shrinking, this extra force
due to the resistive
medium, would
have to shrink by a
specific calculable amount.
We now use the
Greek letter gamma.
If you haven't
seen that already,
you'll see it throughout IAP
and the rest of your life.
It takes this somewhat
simple-looking form--
1 over the square root of
1 minus v over c squared.
If you plot it, you
can see it diverges.
When the relative speed gets
close to the speed of light,
you have 1 minus 1
in the denominator.
You divide by 0.
Your eyes bug out.
And cats and dogs live together.
Everything goes crazy.
So it diverges at v equals c.
On the other hand,
for small speeds,
small compared to
the speed of light,
this factor is
indistinguishable from 1.
So here's a quick plot.
For ordinary speeds that we
encounter on the highway,
let alone on a
bicycle, our speed
compared to the speed of
light is vanishingly small.
So this factor gamma is
very, very close to 1.
Only when you get to speeds
approaching the speed of light
would you expect to measure
any shift from that.
Nonetheless, Lorentz
said in principle this
happens at any speed.
And the shrink, the
amount of contraction,
is governed by
that relative speed
given by this
Greek letter gamma.
So gamma is always greater
than or equal to 1.
That means 1 over gamma
must be smaller than 1.
And that's saying that the
contracted length of one
of those arms of
the interferometer
got shorter by a
certain amount depending
on the relative speed.
That would be enough to
account for this null result,
Lorentz argued.
It turned out that
exact form of gamma
was the same form he'd found
for his mathematical local time
manipulations.
So here's how we can
live in a physical ether
even though we don't
measure its effects.
OK.
Let me now shift to how
a different person began
thinking about very familiar
questions by that point
but coming at them
quite differently.
That's young Albert Einstein.
So Einstein was born in
the midst of all this.
He was born in 1879
in kind of rural,
roughly speaking,
nowheresville Germany,
not near any of the big cities.
So Lorentz was already
a practicing physicist
when Einstein was born.
He was much younger.
Einstein's main
ambition was actually
to become an electrical
engineer at a time
when that term itself
was actually brand new.
Einstein's father and uncle
had gone into business
together in this
really brand new field
of electrical engineering.
This was the age
of electrification.
Think about extended
street lighting,
trolley cars with the
shared electric lines above.
This was transforming
the face of everyday life
in cities and eventually
even in more rural areas.
And Einstein's father and
uncle were in on that.
They were early professionals
in this new field
of electrical engineering.
And Einstein loved it.
He loved to tinker with
electrotechnical gadgets.
He had many strong
feelings about many things.
Among them, he hated
what he considered
the overly militaristic German
high school that he attended.
He would argue and
insult his teachers.
They didn't like him any better.
They were delighted
when he dropped out,
so they didn't have
to kick him out.
He was really very
obnoxious, it turns out.
So he was a high-school dropout.
He dreamed of entering the Swiss
Federal Technical Institute.
It was kind of like
the MIT of Switzerland.
Except to be more proper, MIT
is the Massachusetts version
of their school.
Zurich's was founded first.
It's often called the ETH, or
the Eidgenossische Technische
Hochschule.
It was really a very
elite technical university
in Zurich, Switzerland.
Einstein, by this
point, had renounced
his German citizenship.
He dropped out of high school.
And one of the best things
about this technical university
in Zurich was that
you didn't have
to have a high school diploma.
He said, perfect.
That's the place for me.
So they had an entrance exam,
which he very dutifully studied
for and then failed
because, after all, he
ignored the topics that
weren't of interest to him.
He did well enough on
the physics and math
portions of the overall exam
that a kindly physics professor
took him aside and
said, you know,
if you go to basically a
kind of regional, something
almost like a
community college, go
to a local, regional
school for a year,
study up, retake the
exam, you might do better.
And that's what Einstein did.
So he went to a
little regional school
in, again, in rural
Switzerland for a year,
took the exam again, and passed.
So now he's able
to enter his dream
school, the ETH in Zurich.
Once he then worked
so hard to get in,
he proceeded to cut classes.
This guy was a horrible student.
Whatever you do, don't
be like Albert Einstein,
at least while
you're in university.
He worked so hard to get in.
And then he, again, would
insult his professors
as much as he'd insulted
his high school teachers.
He thought everything
they did was boring.
They didn't know what
was really interesting.
So he would cut classes
and read on his own
and then borrow notes
from his girlfriend,
his long, suffering, very
patient girlfriend, Mileva
Maric, who was doing very well
in her own physics and math
courses.
And likewise, he borrowed
notes from another friend
of his, Marcel Grossmann.
So he'd just cram and scrape
through for the exams.
Not an ideal student.
For some reason that Einstein
couldn't possibly fathom,
because he actually
was a dolt frankly,
he impressed none
of his professors.
So when it came time to
graduate, none of them
would write him a strong
letter of recommendation.
Again, his life bears many
important lessons for us today.
Attend class.
And be slightly less
obnoxious to your instructors.
And maybe things
will turn out better.
So none of his teachers
would basically
support him because
he had middling grades
and he was rude to them.
So he couldn't get a
job after graduation.
So finally one of
his close friends,
Marcel Grossmann,
one of the folks
from whom he'd borrowed notes,
his father had connections.
And so basically
through connections,
he was able to get Einstein
an entry-level civil service
job at the patent office
in Bern, Switzerland.
So still in Switzerland.
He was a patent
officer, third class.
As I'm always fond of saying,
there was no fourth class.
You were the lowest
entry-level gig.
So even for young Einstein,
it wasn't what you know.
It was who you know.
What he then
proceeded to do was he
had a day job at
what they called
the electrotechnical desk, much
like what his father and uncle
were doing.
He was a patent
examiner for a lot
of these cool, new
electrical gadgets.
And then he would go
hang out with a bunch
of friends and drink
beer a lot at the pubs.
So they formed what they
called the Olympia Academy.
And this was very ironic.
They gave themselves
the most elite
sounding name because
they're basically
three semi-bums
hanging out, reading,
and blowing off their families.
So they gave themselves a
very, very prestigious name,
even though it was literally
three recent college
graduates hanging out.
It was Maurice Solovine,
Conrad Habicht,
and young Albert Einstein.
And they would go and sometimes
drink coffee, often drink beer,
and talk about
stuff they'd read.
And they would read
a lot of physics
and read a lot of philosophy
and talk about it.
And one of the books that we
know from their correspondence
at the time that they
were really interested in
was this fascinating book
by an Austrian polymath
named Ernst Mach.
Here's the book translated
into English, known
as The Science of Mechanics.
It had come out in the 1880s.
Mach was really remarkable.
He was both a
mathematical physicist
and experimental physicist.
You might know the
terminology for Mach number,
like speed of sound, Mach 1,
Mach 2, Mach 3-- same Mach.
He did a lot of studies
of acoustics and optics
but also of what we would
now call psychology,
like sensory experiments
and so on, and eventually
medical surgery.
And then at the
end of his career,
he was a professor of the
history and philosophy
of science.
This guy did it all.
He wrote these very, very
dense, conceptual critiques
of Newtonian physics,
among other things.
And Mach was convinced
that Newton was really
getting himself into
a horrible muddle
because he had not paid
sufficient attention
philosophically.
And this is what the young
members of the Olympia Academy
got really excited about.
We know from their letters
and their notes at the time.
Mach was advocating
a position that
came to be known as positivism.
According to Ernst Mach,
unlike Isaac Newton,
or for that matter even some
folks like Maxwell, Mach
argued that only quantities
that could become objects
of positive experience,
that is to say things we
could actively measure or
sense or feel or touch,
only those things belonged
in our scientific theories.
Anything else was just
like mere speculation,
like counting the number
of angels that could
dance on the head of a pin.
He was scathingly
critical of Newton.
And in particular,
Mach wrote in detail
that Newton's notions
of absolute space
and absolute time had no
meaning because how could you
ever measure absolute time?
Show me the clock that
could measure absolute time.
That was the kind of
classic Machian response.
I can measure the passage
of time by using a clock.
But who says that's what
Newton wrote absolute time was?
This had an amazing impact, as
we know, on the young Einstein.
So he's in this milieu.
He's now not in a
university setting.
He scraped through his
undergraduate studies.
He has a nice day job.
But he's not doing particularly
well professionally.
He's hanging out
with his buddies
and reading some interesting
and hard, obscure philosophy
science in the evenings.
Well, he has what's now commonly
called his miraculous year,
his annus mirabilis, in 1905.
In fact, he only took
about six months.
It was, like, half a year,
during which he submitted
four really astonishing,
original papers to the leading
journal of physics,
the Annalen der
Physik in Germany at the time.
They've since been
published and translated.
There's a particularly
nice edition
you can find edited by John
Stachel with very nice essays
to accompany them.
You can find them online.
So for IAP and for
the rest of today
and even throughout
the month, we're
really interested in what was
the third of these articles
that he submitted.
He submitted it to the
journal in June of 1905.
It's on what we would now
call special relativity.
Its title, as you
can see up top,
was actually, in translation,
"On the Electrodynamics
of Moving Bodies," a thoroughly
familiar title, exactly what
Lorentz and all of
Lorentz's colleagues
have been talking about
for decades by that point.
So the title of
Einstein's paper in 1905
was not surprising, even
though, as we'll see,
his approach was quite distinct.
He begins this now very well
done paper not by saying,
I found an error in
Lorentz's calculation.
There was a missing factor
of 2 pi or whatever.
He doesn't say, I conducted
my own measurements.
And I found these results
with an experimental error.
He starts out by saying
there's an asymmetry
in the explanation which is
not present in the phenomena.
It sounds very philosophical.
He goes on in his
very opening paragraph
to say that when we use
Maxwell's equations,
we come up with very different
kinds of accounts for what
should be the same phenomenon.
Very simple.
Nothing super fancy
like an interferometer.
Just take a bar magnet and
a coil through which current
could flow.
And make sure you have a current
meter, an ammeter attached
to the coil.
So if electric current
flows through the coil,
it will be measured.
The ammeter needle
will be deflected.
And we are free to move
either the magnet or the coil.
In his opening paragraph,
Einstein says, physicists
had treated this situation
completely orthogonally even
though, as far as
Einstein was concerned,
there's only one
explanation needed.
And so with case
1, if you assume
the bar magnet is moving,
you're shaking the magnet
back and forth and keeping
the coil fixed in location,
then you would appeal to one
set of Maxwell's equations.
And again, on the t-shirt
it would be this one.
You have a time-varying
magnetic field
which will induce a spatially
varying electric field.
And that will exert a push,
a force on the little ions,
the little electric
charges within that coil.
They'll feel a push.
They'll move along the coil.
Electric current, as
Maxwell himself had argued,
was nothing but the motion of
these electric-charge bearers.
So because you have a
time-varying magnetic field,
the little bits of matter in
the coil will be pushed along.
You'll induce a current.
That's case 1-- moving
magnets, stationary coil.
But if you want to analyze
the other situation,
to hold the magnet
rigidly fixed in place
and shift the coil
back and forth,
then physicists would give an
entirely separate explanation.
They would appeal to a different
one of Maxwell's equations.
Now they'd say that there's
a static magnetic field that
varied in space.
It's spatial gradients
were non-vanishing.
And that would exert a force,
like a kind of Lorentz force
law, on those charges.
So they have some velocity
in a magnetic field.
They'll be pushed
along the wire.
And you'll measure a current.
Einstein said that's one
explanation too many.
All that we could ever measure--
again, you can almost hear the
kind of Mach coming through--
all we can ever see as an
element of positive experience
is some relative motion
between the magnet and the coil
which induces an
electric current.
Who's to say one
was actually still
while the other was moving?
So Einstein begins
this paper by saying
that there's something
wrong with the stories
we tell about the equations.
He doesn't argue
about the equations.
He argues about
our interpretation
of the equations.
Very striking.
He then goes on, just in,
like, paragraph 3-- still
very early in the introduction--
to posit two postulates.
He doesn't prove them.
He doesn't derive them.
He doesn't say, I have
demonstrated these
by doing experiments.
He says, let me hypothesize
these and see what follows.
And these are the two
in rough paraphrase.
The first one was
actually already called
the principle of relativity,
or sometimes simply called
Galilean relativity, going
back again to the 17th century.
Galileo had argued by
thinking about that boat
floating down the river, that
to a person on the boat, as long
as the boat is moving
at a constant speed,
neither speeding up
nor slowing down,
that all the laws of mechanics
should work perfectly well
for that observer the
same as they would
for us at rest on the shore.
If you toss a ball, it'll
land back in your hand
as you expect.
Even though to us,
we see the ball trace
a complicated parabola,
to the person on the boat,
she's perfectly entitled to
say, I'm sitting at rest.
The ball went straight
up and landed straight
back in my hand.
All the laws of mechanics
should work equally well
in any reference frame that's
moving at a constant speed.
Einstein just takes
that existing principle
of relativity from
mechanics and just assumes,
just hypothesizes
that that should
apply not only to mechanics but
to every physical phenomenon--
electricity, magnetism,
optics, thermodynamics.
And that's just a leap.
He just says, what if?
What if this applies to any
kind of physical phenomenon, not
just mechanics?
And then he introduces
the second postulate
which seems actually to be in
tension a bit with the first.
His second postulate
is, the speed of light
is a constant independent
of the motion of the source.
What?
That doesn't sound right.
If you go back to Galileo
and watching his friend
on the boat, if
she fires a cannon,
the speed with which we
measure the cannonball
is different than the speed
she measures it, right?
If you watch her
lobbing a tennis ball,
our measurement of the speed
of an object in her reference
frame is not the same as ours.
And Einstein here
is saying light
is special, that unlike
tennis balls, ping pong balls,
cannonballs, or trains,
or anything else,
the speed of light,
as a postulate,
will be constant
for any observer
as long as they're in an
inertial frame of reference.
And here's an excerpt from
the English translation.
I won't read all this out.
But he says, what follows
from these postulates
is that the luminiferous ether
will prove to be superfluous--
[GERMAN]
He doesn't say, I've
disproven it, ether.
He says it's just irrelevant.
50 years' worth, by that point
100 years' worth of study
by all of Europe's most
prestigious physicists was
irrelevant.
That's probably why he didn't
have many friends in physics
at the time.
So he doesn't
disprove the ether.
He says we just won't even
need to refer to it anymore.
It makes the entire
set of questions
that had driven
people like Lorentz
really kind of fall away,
at least as far as Einstein
himself is concerned.
So why does Einstein introduce
that second postulate?
And again, historians and
physicists and philosophers
have studied this
question a lot.
And we have some good
documentary evidence
because Einstein was
writing letters and diaries
and stuff all the time.
And a lot of those
have survived.
So we have some contemporaneous
documentation as well as
his own later
recollections and so on.
We know that actually 10
years before this paper, back
when Einstein was
a mere teenager,
he'd like to pose these
kind of thought experiments
or questions to himself.
And one of the questions
he would return
to really over the
course of a full decade
was, what would it look like,
what would you experience,
if you could catch
up to a light wave?
And he reasoned it would be like
a surfer riding along an ocean
wave, that to us
on the shore, we'd
see both these things moving.
We would see a dynamical
wave moving over time,
not just a frozen
waveform in space.
But to the surfer,
if she's really
moving at the same
speed as the wave,
then she would see the
wave frozen in time.
It would be a crest
here, a trough there.
At least for some
extended period of time,
the surfer would
see the wave frozen,
not dynamical-- a frozen
waveform varying in space
but frozen in time.
So Einstein said that doesn't
make any sense if we think
about Maxwell's equations.
When he got a little
more sophisticated
and learned more
about Maxwell, he
said there's no solution
to Maxwell's equations.
If you're in a
source-free region,
if there's no clump of
electric charge around,
no electric currents around,
if both rho and J vanish,
then there's no way to
have spatially varying
electric and
magnetic fields that
are nonetheless static, right?
That seems to be
a contradiction.
So how do you get out
of this contradiction
of thinking you would have
a static waveform of light
if you could catch up and
move at the same speed
as that light wave?
How do you avoid that?
You just make sure you can
never catch up to the wave.
How can you never ever
catch up to the wave
if the wave is always
traveling at the speed c
even if you're traveling
on a very fast train or now
a hypersonic jet or a
spaceship of your imagination?
That second postulate
for Einstein we now know
was really the endpoint of
a 10-year series of thought
experiments about,
what would it look
like to catch up
with a light wave?
And he said that would make
so many other things mutually
inconsistent.
Let's make sure no one could
ever catch a light wave.
And that's what
starts driving much
of the rest of his thinking, not
worrying about interferometers
and all the rest.
So what he does, unlike Lorentz
and really all the masters
in the field at
the time, Einstein
begins with kinematics,
with the force-free motion
of bodies through
space and time,
which is a very
Machian thing to do.
What can we see?
We measure objects moving
through space and time.
Whereas people like Lorentz,
and Maxwell for that matter,
have been starting with
forces, with dynamics.
Remember, Lorentz
has this great idea
that there's a force from
the ether on the matter.
And in Michelson's
instrument, it's
all about dynamics, forces.
Einstein inverts that order.
He says forces
will be important.
But first let's make sure we
understand force-free motion
kinematics first.
After all, that's
what could become
objects of positive experience.
And so he has these
wonderful quotations.
It's now from the
introduction of the paper.
It's on the bottom of page 2.
He's really redescribing
how to lay out coordinates.
It sounds childish.
It sounds thoroughly
unprofessional to the folks
of the time.
Hendrik Lorentz says don't
bother with 'what do we mean
by coordinates?'
But Einstein was
convinced we have
to think through how
do we describe motion
through space and time first.
And I won't bother
reading it out.
I'll share this slide.
And you can see it.
But that's really what he's
doing in the very opening
paragraphs of this paper.
And that leads him to other
follow-up conclusions,
one of which very
famously becomes
known as the relativity
of simultaneity.
And you might have
heard of that before.
You'll spend more time
with this in IAP, I'm sure.
If there's no such
thing as absolute time,
if time is what we measure
with time-measuring devices
like clocks, if
that's all time is,
is what can be measured by an
actual instrument like a clock,
then how can we compare the
times in different places?
After all, I'm sitting
here with my clock.
Well, he says one
thing we could do
is trade light signals
because, at least according
to his postulate number
2, light is special.
If I throw ping pong balls,
that's not so special
because we will disagree
on the speed with which
those ping pong balls travel.
If I send a light wave,
then we had better
agree on the speed with which
that light moved from point A
to point B because
of postulate 2.
So he starts thinking about
one of his favorite things
in the universe, trains.
He loved trains.
It came up all the time.
So he imagines a train
moving along a platform
at a constant speed, a nice,
inertial frame of reference.
Einstein is standing here on the
embankment, the train platform.
He has two friends.
We can call them Alice
and Bob, A and B. Einstein
has marked himself out to be in
the perfect midpoint of where
Alice and Bob are standing.
So they mark this all
out ahead of time.
He marks himself
perfectly in the middle.
Alice and Bob are each equipped
with a lantern and a watch.
And by prior
arrangement, they say
at 12:00 noon on the dot,
turn on your lanterns.
So the light will
travel from both A and B
toward the midpoint.
Point your lanterns
toward Einstein
at point M. Turn them
on at the same time.
Meanwhile on this
zooming train, there's
another friend of
Einstein's sitting
at the midpoint of the train.
At the point, this is
Marge, M prime here.
She knows that she's in the
exact midpoint of the train.
She knows by prior
arrangement that Alice and Bob
are standing one train
length apart from each other.
And again, she's expecting that
they will turn their lanterns
on at the same time.
So how do these different
folks describe this series
of events that follow?
Let's focus first
on what Einstein
sees when he's standing
still on the train
platform, the embankment,
watching the train go by.
The observer who's
standing still
on the platform at point M
was, by prior arrangement,
at equal distance
from Alice and Bob.
I guess I changed it.
Now it's a she.
So Mileva, his wife,
is standing there.
Maybe M stands for Mileva.
So she receives the light
waves from points A and B
at the same time.
So she can conclude that the
light flashes were emitted
at the same time, that the
event of person A and person
B shining the lights, those
events were simultaneous.
How do you know?
Because the light had
equal distances to travel.
And the light could only
travel at but one speed.
And they arrived
at the same time.
They must have started the
journeys at the same time.
The act of shining
those lanterns
must have been simultaneous.
But what about the person
who's on the moving train?
She sees the following as she is
zooming along at point M prime.
She sees the light from point
B arrive at her location first.
Now, Mileva or
Einstein would say, oh,
that's because you're
racing toward it.
She says, not so fast.
I'm in a perfectly
self-consistent
mechanical system.
All the laws of physics work
as well for me as for you.
And the light
couldn't have sped up
or slowed down by
your own postulate,
she would say-- she
would be entitled to say.
So if she's equal distant
between points A and B
and she receives the
light from B first,
the only possible explanation
is that the lights were not
shown simultaneously, that A
and B did not turn the lanterns
on at the same time.
So the person on the train
platform and the person
on the moving train
disagree about what
happens simultaneously.
This becomes known as the
relativity of simultaneity.
So who's correct?
I've already said, according
to Einstein, no one or both
of them because of postulate 1.
They're both
entitled to work out
a perfectly
self-consistent set of laws
involving electromagnetism,
optics, and mechanics.
They agree they were
at the midpoint.
They agree that light didn't
speed up or slow down.
So they are both
right, which is to say
there is no right answer
to the question, what
was really simultaneous?
Simultaneity becomes relative
to one's frame of reference.
That's a pretty deep change
from the Newtonian system.
And as Einstein says--
again, it's bottom of page 2,
very early in the paper--
"we see that we can
attribute no absolute meaning
to the concept of simultaneity,
but that two events which
examined from a
coordinate system
are simultaneous"-- like
him on the embankment--
"can no longer be interpreted
as simultaneous events when
examined from a system
which is in motion
relative to that system."
OK, that's about kinematics.
It's not about forces or
resistive medium or dynamics.
So now he goes on-- again,
very early on in the paper--
once you get to the relativity
of simultaneity-- again,
as you'll have a chance to
unpack with more patience
in the coming days and weeks--
other strange phenomena
seem to follow from that,
argues Einstein.
One of the first he talks
about is length contraction.
So this had been found
and published by Lorentz.
Einstein is about to give an
entirely different derivation,
even though quantitatively it's
the same form of the equation.
For Einstein, it has
nothing to do with forces.
It's all about kinematics.
In general, like a
good Machian, he asks,
how do we measure the
length of an object?
How do we make length an
object of positive experience?
Well, at the same time
measure the location
of the front of the object
and the back of the object
and take the difference.
So if you want to measure
the length of the train,
that's fine.
Just measure where the
front is and the back
is at the same time,
and then mark off
the difference between those
two locations in space.
Our friends Alice and Bob
can do that with the train.
And they find the answer capital
L. The train is length L long.
Meanwhile, Alice and Bob--
and I should say that's
when the train is at rest.
When they do this
with a moving train,
Alice and Bob measure the
length of a moving train,
they measure some
length shorter than what
the person on the
train was expecting.
The person on the train expected
the full length L. The person
who's moving with the object,
either at rest with it
or moving together with it,
says the train is L units long.
But when Alice and
Bob measure the train
by measuring the front
and back at the same time,
they find a shorter answer.
They found it shrunk along
the direction of motion
by some specific amount.
Now, how could that be?
Remember, we disagree
about "at the same time."
So if we disagree
about simultaneity,
we will-- perforce,
we must start
to disagree about lengths.
So the person on the train says,
you did your measurement wrong.
You measured the front
of the train first.
We know that event B
happened first, she says,
because we got the light
from event B first.
So you measured the
front of the train
and then waited while the train
slid and then later measured
the position of the
rear of the train.
So of course you have
a shorter distance
because you performed
a bad measurement,
because you didn't
measure the front
and back at the same time.
We say, don't be silly.
They were at the same time.
We checked by
trading light beams.
We know they were simultaneous.
And we got the answer L prime.
Your train is short.
Who's right?
Sort of both and neither,
that because we disagree
on simultaneity, we
disagree on the outcomes
of simultaneous events like
measurements of length.
And so he goes on with
just a few lines of algebra
to find the exact form
of what was already
known as the Lorentz
contraction, that same factor
gamma that you'll
be using all IAP,
that the measurement
of an object in motion
shrinks along the
direction of motion.
Whereas if we were at
rest with that object,
we'd find a longer length.
And the amount it shrinks
depends on that relative speed
v over c.
It depends, in particular,
on this form gamma.
This has nothing, for Einstein,
to do with forces or dynamics.
It's a totally different
derivation than Lorentz's.
It's simply a consequence of
kinematics and, in particular,
about simultaneity.
It's a very simple exercise.
You'll probably wind
up doing it very soon
to find a similar consequence
for the rate at which clocks
will tick.
This has now became
known as time dilation.
Imagine a very simple kind
of clock, the simplest one--
two highly polished
mirrors with a light beam
that just bounces straight
back and forth between them.
If the clock is at rest
with respect to us,
we hold the clock perfectly
still at a fixed height,
then the time it
takes for that light
to travel from the bottom
mirror to the top mirror
will count as one
tick of our clock.
[SNAPPING]
And we know that light can
only travel at a fixed speed.
So it's a really
great, uniform clock.
As long as we can hold
that height really fixed,
this is a great way of defining
a unit of time and therefore
our clock rate.
What happens if our friend
has an identical clock,
same mirrors, held equally
rigidly at the same height
apart but zooming past
us on that moving train?
Then we watch the light
have to travel this longer
path because after the light
beam leaves the bottom mirror,
in order to reach
the top mirror,
the whole assembly has moved
with the train to the right,
some distance v times t
in the time during which
that light beam was in transit.
So it has to travel
the hypotenuse
of this right triangle.
Instead of just this
simple up and down,
it travels perforce
a longer distance
and likewise back down.
So our observation
of the moving clock
is that it takes
longer between ticks.
That becomes known
as time dilation.
The time between
ticks has stretched,
which is to say the clock is
running slowly as we measure.
We measure the moving
clock to run slowly
by that same factor gamma.
The time between
ticks gets stretched.
Remember, gamma
is greater than 1.
So the time between
ticks gets stretched.
And that's the same with
the clock is running slowly.
Meanwhile, the person on the
train says, you're ridiculous.
I had the clock with
me the whole time.
It kept perfect time.
But your clock ran slowly.
I watched as I ran
by the station.
Perfectly symmetrical
conclusions.
So Einstein was working all
this out, very much inspired
by Ernst Mach, by this notion
of positivism, of what can we
hope to measure, not
starting with forces
but with the force-free
motion of objects
through space and time, and
really trying to bring it back
to, what would be measurable?
What would I see if I
were in this situation?
One of his teachers at
the ETH, a mathematician
named Hermann Minkowski, had
formed a deservedly low opinion
of student Einstein.
Einstein used to cut
class, was very rude.
But one of their mutual
friends, after Einstein's paper
came out, sent the paper to
Minkowski saying, you know,
it's actually kind
of interesting.
Take a look, to paraphrase.
And Minkowski said,
well, despite the fact
that I knew Einstein was never
going to amount to anything,
I read the paper.
And I was right, Minkowski says.
He really made a mess
of this, as well.
So Minkowski's just
interested enough
to redo Einstein's
work in a form that
made much more
sense to Minkowski,
who was, after all, a
professional geometer.
He wasn't just a mathematician.
He loved geometry most of all.
So Minkowski, not
Einstein, is the one
who actually brings
these pieces together
a few years later
in-- it was published
in 1908 instead of 1905.
And he says, all this
talk about moving trains
and polished mirrors, all of
that's just a distraction.
To a properly trained
mathematician,
which Einstein was
not, all we're doing
is performing rotations
or projections
in a certain kind of
space, in this case
a spacetime in which there's,
say, one direction of space
running along the
horizontal axis
and one dimension of
time running up the page.
We now call these
Minkowski diagrams
in his honor, or simply
spacetime diagrams.
None of this appears in
Einstein's early work.
This was done by his
former teacher in response
to what Minkowski considered
to be Einstein's continuing
confusion and sloppiness.
And there's a benefit from
doing that, Minkowski finds.
He agrees with Einstein
that we will disagree
on certain kinds
of measurements,
for example lengths
and durations of time,
because we disagree
on simultaneity.
But Minkowski finds
something that had not been
so clear to Einstein himself.
There are combinations of
those kinds of intervals
on which we will all agree.
This is what we would now
call a spacetime invariant.
Put together, a combination
of the time interval
minus the space interval, a
relative minus sign and each
of those quantities
squared, that combination
we will all agree
on as long as we're
each in states of
non-accelerating motion
even though we
disagree separately
on the duration between two
events, delta t, or the lengths
between them, delta x.
And that, from Minkowski, is
what any geometer should do.
Some relationships
remain invariant
even under changes
of coordinates.
And for Minkowski, that was
what any undergraduate geometry
student should know to do first.
So we actually have
this notion of one kind
of thing called spacetime coming
from Minkowski kind of redoing
Einstein's work.
And as Minkowski famously
writes in his own article--
it was published posthumously;
he died quite young.
And he gave a lecture.
And it was published
soon after he died.
And he wrote upon
introducing this new work,
"Henceforth space
by itself and time
by itself are doomed to
fade away into mere shadows
and only a kind of
union of the two
will preserve independence."
And by shadows, he really
meant projections, just
drop perpendicular to
the appropriate axis
and then think about
coordinate transformations
in that spacetime of x and t.
So that's, again,
something you'll
get much more practice with if
you haven't seen it already.
But that's a preview.
That comes in response
to Einstein's work.
It wasn't an Einstein's
own original.
Although, just to jump
ahead very briefly,
Einstein first thought
that was horrible
because he didn't
like Minkowski.
But then over the
next several years,
the better part of
a decade, Einstein
himself became more impressed
by that way of thinking
and really adopted it
for his own later work
on what became known as the
general theory of relativity.
That's for later.
OK, very briefly
here's the third part
of the material I wanted
to share with you.
And then hopefully there'll
be some time for discussion,
as well.
So this last part
is much more brief.
But it's, how do we
make sense of this?
Why was Einstein doing all
this seemingly unusual,
maybe even crazy
stuff, certainly
out of step with Lorentz,
with his own teachers
like Minkowski?
How can we account for
Einstein's quite idiosyncratic
approach to what was otherwise
a common set of questions
about the electrodynamics
of moving bodies?
Now, here's some of my favorite
work by other colleagues,
by other historians and
physicists who really
looked at this in great detail.
So for a long, long
time, I mean literally
for the better
part of 100 years,
since people began taking
relativity seriously,
which is a long time by now, it
had become very common to say,
well, Einstein must
have been motivated
much like Hendrik Lorentz
was, really like that
much of that generation was.
Einstein must have
been responding
to the null result from
Michelson and Morley
and their interferometer,
that Einstein
must have been trying to explain
why they couldn't measure
our motion through the ether
much as Lorentz, we know,
very explicitly
was trying to do.
And there's a fascinating--
one of the first really careful
examinations of that claim
was by Gerald Holton, who's
a real kind of hero of mine.
Holton did his first
PhD in physics,
low-temperature physics, and
then retooled many years later
in the history of science.
And he wrote a series of
really remarkable essays
about Einstein once a lot of
Einstein's papers and letters
and notes became available.
Holton was among the
first to really dig
through these with
great care and almost
like a detective going
through the evidence.
And what Holton
concluded was it's
not clear that
Einstein even knew
about the Michelson-Morley
interferometer.
Lorentz knew about it and
followed it carefully.
There's very little trace that
Einstein paid it any attention
at all.
If he did know about it,
it was kind of in passing.
It was certainly not front of
mind in the months and years
leading up to the 1905 paper.
He might have known
about it secondhand
from reading through all
the footnotes of Lorentz.
But it's not something he
seems to have been paying
much attention to at all.
And so there's nice
textual evidence
even in Einstein's
paper, that 1905 paper
that I keep showing some
brief excerpts from.
Again, this is on the
first or second page.
When he's trying to reason why
we should think about maybe
giving up on the
ether, he mentions--
without citing any
of them-- he mentions
several unsuccessful
attempts to discover
any motion of the Earth relative
to the light medium, the ether.
He doesn't say
which ones he means.
But he actually then goes on
to say in the same paragraph,
none of these have found any
deviation to first order in v
over c.
And what's so striking,
as Holton reminds us,
is Michelson-Morley was
actually second order.
Einstein seems to be talking
about a whole different class
of earlier experiments
even before Michelson
got in the game.
He's certainly
not obsessing over
the Michelson-Morley
interferometer the way
other people were.
And so some people then
read Holton's analysis
to say a kind of overcorrection.
Does that mean
Einstein didn't care
about any kinds of
experiments at all?
If he wasn't trying
to respond directly
to the Michelson-Morley
experiment,
was he just off in a kind of
philosophical dream world?
And that's where
I think we again
can now say quite firmly no.
In fact, it makes
sense to go back
to Einstein's own early
years, his early fascination
with electrotechnical
gadgets, and remind ourselves
what his day job was in the
early 1900s, including 1905.
Put him back in the patent
office in Central Europe
at this very specific moment.
So let's think about Einstein's
favorite technology, trains.
Trains and railroads
themselves were actually
fairly new in the 19th century.
They were introduced to
widespread commercial usage
for commercial
transportation really only
in the 1830s and '40s.
Remember, Einstein
was born in 1879.
They were relatively new
even in his childhood.
During this whole time until
very late in the 19th century,
there were no
coordinated time zones.
There was nothing like Eastern
Standard Time or Pacific
Time or Central European Time.
Each town set its
own local time.
And all the residents
could coordinate
by agreeing that we'll use
that clock tower, either
some municipal building or
often a tall church in the town
square, say that's
our local time.
We'll set our local
watches to when
that clock chimes 12:00 noon.
So each town kept
its own local time.
And before railway, who would
ever need anything else?
Because one was rarely
encountering more than one
town in a given day.
After the advent of railroads,
you still have this local time.
But that became more
and more of a problem.
It was true in North
America as in Europe
and other parts of
the world, as well.
So here, closer to
Boston, passengers
riding on the train
between Boston and New York
during this time would have
to change their watches
by an average of 37 minutes.
Today we're all in
the same time zone.
But that's how different
the local variations
tended to be just
up and down the US
portion of the
mid-Atlantic seacoast
and likewise throughout Europe.
That was becoming more
and more of a problem
when you have to coordinate
lots of trains traveling
across large distances.
It wasn't only a problem
for commercial railway
or for shipping.
It became a very potent,
added challenge in Germany
during Einstein's youth.
So again, as many
of you may know,
there only became
one single country
of Germany, a unified
Germany, in 1871 following
yet another war with France.
That was basically the story
of the previous 500 years,
German-speaking lands fighting
with French-speaking ones.
There was another one,
the Franco-Prussian war,
throughout 1870.
The German-speaking
folks prevailed.
And it was at that moment,
in the wake of that war,
that there was then
a first unification
of a country of Germany, now
a much larger expanse of what
had otherwise been independent
German-speaking territories.
So now there's an
added reason to worry
about trains that have to be
coordinated across distances.
There's now a new
country's worth
that has to defend its borders
all the way from basically
Poland or Russia on the
East and France on the West.
And there's a famous quotation
from a leading German general,
Count von Moltke,
who in the 1890s, 20
years into German unification,
is basically saying,
we have a problem on our hands.
We have to coordinate
trains for military purposes
as well as commercial, passenger
rail, and merchant shipping.
We have a problem
with the fact that we
don't have unified time zones.
This is all happening
in Einstein's childhood.
Remember, Einstein
was born in 1879,
very early in this
period of unified Germany
and a new focus on coordinating
clocks at a distance.
So one of the main ideas that
many clever people, inventors,
came up with throughout Europe
and other parts of the world,
as well, was to try
to coordinate clocks
and therefore help
coordinate train stations
in these different cities.
Now, much of continental
Europe was now
being connected by rail.
If the major hubs, if
the major train stations
could agree on the time, then
you could set your watch then.
And the trains could be better
coordinated throughout even
into the hinterlands.
And the main idea that many
inventors and entrepreneurs
kind of zeroed in on was
to install these so-called
[GERMAN] clocks, mother
clocks, central clocks
that you would say
were the standard ones.
And then connect those by
electromagnetic signal,
either telegraph or,
increasingly, radio waves,
literally traveling
electromagnetic waves
in the ether.
Some of you might know that
the Eiffel Tower, which
is under construction
in just this period,
was originally built to
aid radio communication.
It was a radio beacon before
it was a reason for all of us
to go visit Paris.
There were other
reasons before that.
The Eiffel Tower
was built really
in this period in large
part to become a radio
beacon to broadcast
standardized time signals.
And then the idea
was you would know
how far you were from Paris.
You know there'd be some
delay of when you'd expect
to receive the radio beacon.
If it's 12:00 noon in Paris
when that beam was sent,
you have an offset based
on how far away you are
and the speed of light that
it would take to get there.
So then these very
clever folks who
make all these gadgets
to both receive
the time, either
telegraph or radio wave,
and then implement the
offset and then reset
the clock in your next
train station clock
and down the line.
So imagine these coordinated
sets of coordinates
where you have local clocks at
every important location that
are sending and receiving
electromagnetic signals
to coordinate the local time.
That's exactly the
scenario that Einstein
mentions in the
abstract in the opening
pages of his 1905 paper.
He doesn't talk about
these patent applications
or about trains in this
more practical way.
But it turns out, as my
friend Peter Galison shows
in this beautiful book
Einstein's Clocks,
Poincare's Maps,
this is the subject
of an enormous tech spree.
This was the tech challenge
of the day for all these
very smart, young
electrical engineers
to build up and patent every
bit, every switch and gear,
for this way of coordinating
clocks at a distance often
using electromagnetic signals.
Not only that, Einstein was
at the electrotechnical part
of the Bern patent office,
where a lot of these
were flowing through.
So he was an examiner on
many of the little widgets
and gadgets as part of this
clock-coordination sequence.
Even better, my favorite part
of Peter's otherwise quite
fascinating book, was that Peter
and his research assistants
pieced together the
walk that Einstein
used to take from his
apartment to the office--
he had a lovely
stroll through Bern
during this time of his life--
and then finding out when each
of the clocks along his route
were wired up to this
now coordinated system.
So literally the
clocks that Einstein
would walk past
between his apartment
and his office were in this
exact moment being wired up
in this new, explicit,
electrotechnical clock
coordination system, not just
across distant train stations
but soon even across
the semi-urban regions
where he lived.
It was literally his
day job and the path
that he walked to get to work.
So this notion of using
electromagnetic signals
to coordinate clocks in a
measurable, repeatable way
was of philosophical interest.
It was certainly
inspired in part
by the writing of Ernst Mach.
But Einstein was also immersed
in a different set of realities
than someone like
Hendrik Lorentz
or the other Maxwellians.
And so when he comes to the
question of electrodynamics
of moving bodies,
Einstein's immersed
in different conversations
and day-to-day questions
compared to those of the
physics elite of his day.
So we come back to this very
iconic but kind of unusual
paper from 1905, "On
the Electrodynamics
of Moving Bodies."
I think we can make a bit more
sense of it, informed by work
by people like Peter Galison.
Einstein's paper has
almost no references.
Much like many
patent applications,
you want to emphasize priority
and downplay precedence.
Einstein focuses on the
operational details.
How would you actually
perform these measurements
and compare the answers
at some distance?
It starts to look sort of
like a patent application,
not like a fancy exercise
in mathematical physics.
So we can come back
to this question of,
why was Einstein doing
things differently?
And what was he up to?
And we see him really enmeshed
in just a different set
of ideas, of philosophical
conversations,
of mathematical techniques,
and also of actual gadgets
compared to some of the
other experts of his day.